For me, this lesson is about
one of the most fun and
interesting topics in
parallel computing.
Namely, the problem of
graph partitioning.
A common thread in a distributed
memory algorithm is,
how do you distribute the data?
For instance, there's a lesson in this
course on distributed breadth-first
search or BFS.
Distributive BFS needs
a way to choose an initial
partitioning of the input graph.
Now that lesson left us
choice of the black box.
This lesson fills in the box.
Before we start, I want to hint at one
of the techniques which I happen to
think is especially neat.
It's called spectral partitioning.
Spectral partitioning exploits
the connection between graphs and
linear algebra, but
it also has an unusual interpretation,
which it turns out is
really kind of fun.
It's a physics-based interpretation
based on systems of springs.